I'm joined now in the studio by Sultan
Barakat professor of public policy at
hammed bin Khalifa University good to
have you with us again uh Sultan let's
just talk uh about the decision by the
high court are we now looking at a real
collision between the the legal
fraternity and courts and the
government yes I mean it's a major
setback particularly for Netanyahu
because he's pushed really hard to try
and introduce these changes in the legal
system within Israel whereby the uh
Supreme Court more or less uh become
less independent and under the thumb of
the government and of course uh Israeli
population citizens have rejected this
and there were all these waves of
protest and so on and I think it will
make a a qualitative difference to them
but for the Palestinians it won't make a
huge difference because the Palestinians
are still governed under emergency
occupation laws that uh the Justice
brought by the Supreme Council does not
really apply to them uh um I I think
it's just another setback for Netanyahu
and um it will probably help I increase
the questioning within the Israeli
Society of what he's been up to that
this is not the only faulty decision
that he's backed this war is another one
do you think he'll put that on the back
burner while the war in Gaza takes
priority at the moment or do you think
he'll bring it alongside it because if
he does the public themselves in Israel
and have a problem of you know coming
back out onto the streets again
while they're still supporting the
government on on a war in I don't think
they will be able to come up on the
streets in the mass as they did in the
past because uh as long as the status of
War persist which he has introduced as
we said maybe in the past it's the first
time Israel declares war since
1973 they invaded Lebanon without
declaring war it was always Special
Operations but by declaring war he has
in change the whole mechanism the
governance is in the hand of the mini
cabinet and they don't have to follow
all the checks and balances that usually
exist in the system and he can suspend a
lot of that protest against him until
the war in Gaza is over and he has you
know until he declares an end a former
end to the war but certainly not ending
in terms of the pressure that the
government and of course Netanyahu uh
face right now because they have decided
that they will attend the international
criminal justice hearings a petition by
South Africa accusing uh Israel of
genocide specifically on the issue of
Gaza uh and the war on Gaza um they
couldn't avoid not attending these
hearings could they no first as a member
of the United Nations and as we saying
before they're very keen on being
counted as a state the core the
addressing the court with respect is is
important for all states and obviously
because South Africa approached under
the genocide Convention of which Israel
is a signature one of the early
signatures to the convention from August
1949 uh these two factors make it
impossible for them to uh reject the the
court hearing uh as it happens now I
think the issue is becomes on how they
defend themselves and to what extent
South Africa and a very important
International Community is going to
support South a Africa in building the
case and the evidence including the
non-govermental agencies un agencies all
the people who witnessed what was going
on uh over the last 3 months how
difficult is it going to be to prove the
case cuz legal loopholes can always
exist can't they are there loopholes
here that is Israel can use I mean
there's the the only loophole is the
fact that it's been at War it has the
right to defend itself uh they have done
every U possible measure to reduce
casualties uh that's what I think what
the Israeli defense is going to be but
uh given the the the way evidence has
been being documented particular on Al
jaaz and other other uh TV channels uh
it's it's going to be difficult I think
to for them to walk away and uh scarred
from this particular court well UNP pick
more as the day progresses certainly
what comes out of that cabinet meeting
later on on our thanks very much thank
you